WHAT A POINTEN THE IRS AGENTS AS
WELL.
>>> THIS JUST IN.
SIGNIFICANT BREAKING NEWS AS
WELL.
CHINESE PRESIDENT XI JINPING
SPOKE WITH UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
VOLODYMR ZELENSKYY ON THE PHONE
THIS MORNING.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME THAT THE
TWO LEADERS HAVE TALKED SINCE
RUSSIA INVADED UKRAINE.
ZELENSKYY SAID IN A STATEMENT
ABOUT THE CALL, IT WAS A LONG
AND MEANINGFUL CONVERSATION.
LAST MONTH XI JINPING VISITED
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
FOR TALKS WHERE THEY POSED AS
PEACE BROKERS FOR RUSSIA'S
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
NO ONE BETTER TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THIS THAN OUR CHIEF
INTERNATIONAL ANCHOR CHRISTIANE
AMANPOUR WHO HAS COVERED THIS
EXTENSIVELY.
HOW BIG IS IT?
>> LOOK, IT'S BIG.
I MEAN, THESE GUYS HAVE BEEN
SAYING THEY WOULD TALK EVER
SINCE XI WENT TO HIS GOOD BUDDY
FOR LIFE VLADIMIR PUTIN IN
MOSCOW.
>> BEST FRIENDS, THEY SAID.
>> BEST FRIENDS, NO HOLDS BARRED
ALLIANCE.
A TROUBLING ALLIANCE BECAUSE TO
SEEMS TO BE A GROWING ALLIANCE
AGAINST THE UNITED STATES IN THE
WEST.
RUSSIA, CHINA, IRAN, ET CETERA.
THE THING IS, WHAT DID PRESIDENT
XI SAY TO PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY?
CHINA IS A MASSIVE PARTNER,
ESPECIALLY IN THE PAST.
A MASSIVE ECONOMIC PARTNER FOR
UKRAINE.
BUT CHINA'S VIEW OF BEING A
PEACE BROKER UP UNTIL NOW HAS
MEANT PARROTING VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
POSITION.
SO RIGHT NOW, UNLESS SOMETHING
CHANGED ON THAT PHONE CALL,
THERE IS NO REAL WAY FOR CHINA
TO SHOW THAT IT IS AN HONEST
BROKER AND NOT JUST CARRYING
WATER FOR PRESIDENT PUTIN.
THIS IS A PROBLEM BECAUSE SOME
OTHER DEMOCRATIC LEADERS SUCH AS
PRESIDENT LULA, LEFT WING, CHINA
IS HIS OWN AUTOCRATIC CAMP.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO DOESN'T
BELIEVE IN THE U.S. SUPPORT OF
UKRAINE AND BELIEVES THERE
SHOULD BE SOME KIND OF PEACE TO
BE BROKERED.
OBVIOUSLY, EVERYBODY WOULD LIKE
IT THAT.
BUT THE CONDITIONS, ACCORDING TO
UKRAINE, ARE NOT YET RIGHT FOR
THAT.
>> IT'S INTERESTING TO HEAR
ZELENSKYY'S TAKE OF THE CALL
SAYING IT WAS LONG, MEANINGFUL
AND THAT THAT CALL IN ADDITION
TO UKRAINE'S AMBASSADOR TO CHINA
BEING A APPOINTED HE BELIEVES
WILL GIVE A POWERFUL IMP TESS TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF BILATERAL --
>> THE TWO HAVE HAD A CALL.
THERE IS A READ OUT, AS OFTEN
HAPPENS.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT THING THAT THE
TWO LEADERS HAVE SPOKEN.
CHINA IS A MASSIVE, MASSIVE
PLAYER AS WE ALL KNOW.
THE QUESTION IS, WHAT IS THE
QUALITY OF THAT CONVERSATION AND
WHAT IS CHINA PREPARED TO DO TO
PRESSURE HIS, YOU KNOW, XI'S
BEST FRIEND PUTIN TO ACTUALLY
COME TO THE TABLE AND STOP WHAT
IS GENERALLY DEEMED BY THE
UNITED NATIONS AS AN ILLEGAL
REINVASION OF UKRAINE.
SO THAT IS REALLY THE KEY.
AND THE REAL KEY IS WHETHER THE
UNITED STATES AND ITS ALLIES
WILL REMAIN REALLY VESTED IN
THIS PROCESS OF DEFENSE THAT
THEY HAVE PUT SO MUCH INTO UNTIL
THERE IS A POSITION WHERE
UKRAINE IS MILITARILY CAPABLE OF
PUTTING PAIN TO RUSSIA AND,
THEREFORE, CREATING THE
CONDITIONS FOR A NEGOTIATION.
RIGHT NOW RUSSIA DOESN'T HAVE TO
NEGOTIATE.
IT'S DOING BADLY, BUT, YOU KNOW.
>> NO ONE IS ON WINNING.
>> RIGHT.
AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
ALEXEY NAVALNY AND THE UPDATES
WE HAVE ON HIM?
>> SO, LOOK, VLADIMIR PUTIN
CONSIDERS ALEXEY NAVALNY AS WELL
AS UKRAINE AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT.
THEY WANT TO BRING DEMOCRACY AND
AN END TO THE AUTOCRATIC REGIME
OF PUTIN AND TRY TO SPEAK
RECRUIT, UKRAINE IN THE WAY IT
ACTS AS AN INDEPENDENT AND
DEMOCRATIC STATE AND A HALF AND
A HALF AS THE KEY OPPOSITION.
SO PUTIN AND THE REGIME THERE IS
JUST OVER AND OVER AGAIN ADDING
MORE CHARGES, MORE THREATS, MORE
COURT APPEARANCES.
SO NOW HE IS FACING TWO TRIALS
AND CASES, ONE OF EXTREMISM, ONE
OF TERRORISM, WHAT THE
DIFFERENCE IS, I AM NOT SURE.
HIS FAMILY SAYS HE HAS BIN GIVEN
TEN DAYS TO GO THROUGH A MASSIVE
DOSSIER.
AND THIS IS WHAT PUTIN DOES.
HE TRIES TO MAKE RELEVANT HIS
OPPOSITION AND THAT'S WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
>> TO SEE THAT PICTURE WE JUST
HAD SHOWS HOW MUCH THINN